Nobel laureates in physics chemistry
laureate in economics sciences your
excellencies members of the Academy
ladies and gentlemen so nice to see so
many of you here today everyone is born
curious this is what makes you most
interesting the more we understand the
more we want to understand but some of
us keep a desire to see and understand
which goes beyond most of us and use the
a curiosity in an ingenious way to
explore and discover all the magic
things that our world is full of Albert
Einstein said I have no special talents
I'm only passionately curious I don't
believe that to achieve what he did but
this year's laureates dead curiosity is
certainly needed but not sufficient
talent is also needed curiosity means
asking questions and try be prepared to
receive any answer not just the one that
was expected what characterizes the
creative mind is the ability to identify
the questions that lead to new
discoveries and to come up with ways to
find the answers this is how we expand
our knowledge about ourselves and about
the world we live in how we improve the
conditions for our lives man has made
and used tools
versus premier tostone fire from the
gods and showed us how to use it in
order to manage everyday life as well as
to enable new discoveries the way humans
make and use tools his perhaps four sets
or species apart more than anything else
renewable questions by asked available
tools may not be sufficient to find the
accurate answers but do tools or ever
increasing complexity may be needed this
requires not only scientific excellence
but also technological skills new tools
and new methodologies have taught us
about the secrets of life allowed us to
look into the world of the tiny
constituents of this cell responsible
for life
the highly symmetrical and beautiful
audience with ability to attack all
forms of life they have told us about
the history of the universe from the
universe closer and closer to the origin
of everything as expressed in printed
form by Harley white LIGO Santander have
finally disclosed those gravitational
waves iced and proposed that travel
along with the swiftness of life it
can't be obstructed in their spatial
flight miles of steel tubing in L shape
position or vacant chambers used in the
mission foregoing expansions and
fluctuations with an outcome exceeding
expectations
these are certainly great achievements
which have largely contributed to our
understanding of how life works and how
the world came about but to understand
the behavior of human beings is at least
as complicated there are no natural laws
to lean against since humans are
equipped with limited rationality social
preferences and thank was self-control
we pray and lead us not into temptation
but deliver us from the evil but are
trapped by the seven deadly sins by
greed and gluttony and by desire to
acquire and possess more than one needs
to constantly make questionable
decisions and not change the behavior
Alfred Nobel he recognized the
importance of science and those who
uncovered what has been hidden who
explained our mere existence who improve
the quality of our lives who open doors
for future finding this week is the big
celebration of science and today you are
all welcome to listen to the laureates
who have Biden or understanding of the
world we live in and of ourselves I will
now ask professor Neves more to share on
the Nobel Committee of physics to
present the Nobel Prize in Physics
[Applause]
okay most welcome
my name is needs Mortensen from Uppsala
University and I'm the chairman of the
Nobel Committee for physics and it's my
great pleasure and it's a great honor to
introduce this year's Nobel laureates in
physics so more than a billion years ago
two black holes merged far far away and
they created gravitational waves ripples
in space-time which travel at the speed
of light through universe on the 14th of
September 2015
these waves post earth and they were
then captured by the like or detected
detectors producing the signal you can
see here and in a fraction of a second
it was all over this is an incredibly
weak signal and I'm still amazed that it
was possible to detect this at all and
gravitational waves were predicted by
Einstein hundred years ago but it is
only now they have been detected and
with this remarkable achievement we now
witness the dawn of a new field
gravitational wave astronomy this clowns
efforts by a large and international
team of scientists and engineers within
the LIGO and Virgo collaborations and
which has been going on for several
decades at the same time you can
identify individuals without whom this
would not have happened
and today's normal laureates also
represent in an excellent way the
diverse competence is needed for the
success of LIGO so today's laureates are
Reiner wise the like burger
collaboration and the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology Barry C bearish
like very good collaboration and
California Institute of Technology in
Pasadena California and Kip has so on
like a Virgo collaboration telephone
Institute of Technology Pasadena and
they get this board with a citation for
decisive contributions to the LIGO
detector and that will detect in the
observation of gravitational waves and
with that I call the first speaker to
give us a Nobel lecture and that is
Professor Rainer Weiss
[Applause]
[Music]
well this is a pleasure to be here but
before I start I want to acknowledge
that the three of us wouldn't be here at
all if it weren't for people who were in
the LIGO laboratory in the LIGO
scientific collaboration and in the
Virgo collaboration and the Virgo
experiment and since some of you are
here I'm going to insist that you stand
up would you please do that
[Applause]
they are really the reason we're here
and now we're the three of us are gonna
give a talk which on the surface looks
the same
you saw the titles like oh and sign and
gravitational waves and I'll give you a
little preview it's and we won't really
be able to hold in this preview exactly
I'll talk about the old times I'm the
oldest and and very will talk about the
present and Kip will talk about the
future now it's not gonna go quite that
way and we will intermingle the times so
don't forgive us but that's the basic
structure so let me start by those of
you and who don't really know much about
gravitational waves and gravity this is
mostly a little bit of a pedagogical
thing in the beginning as most of you
were trained in in high school and
possibly in college is you learnt about
Newton's theory of gravity which is a
theory in which there are forces that
between masses and that force gets
smaller the bigger the distance between
the masses and it is a wonderful theory
it does almost all you need in fact it
got the space program working there's
nothing terribly wrong with that theory
but it isn't right okay
and Einstein saw this pretty quickly
after he developed the special theory of
relativity it doesn't have a way in it
of dealing with very large masses moving
at high velocities that's not in in in
an Newton's theory at all and nor does
it have a way of communicating
information in the gravitational field
from one place to the other for example
if the Sun disappeared and we know it
takes about nine minutes for us to see
that it also should take something like
nine minutes for us to find out
navigational e that it has something has
happened to it and that's something that
again was not in in the Newton theory
and so this picture which is hardly
complete but in some way to imagine this
new theory that Einstein developed is if
you imagine a jungle-gym a big assembly
that you played in as kids in New York
where I was there were lots of those and
you take a cut through it
and you have laid out all those bars and
you've done one more thing which isn't
something you did when you were a kid
you laid clocks out on every
intersection point all along here you
put clocks everywhere and what the
Einstein theory says is what this
picture is trying to show if you take a
cut through it there will be when you're
far away from the Sun that's the Sun and
when you're far away from the earth when
you're far away from those let's say out
here space itself looks our Euclidean it
looks the same way as a jungle gym did
but and the clocks that are running on
all those intersection points they all
read the same time but as you walk
toward the Sun in this plane you'll
notice that the distortion in space you
don't see the distortion in time because
I didn't put your clocks there but the
clocks in here are running a little more
slowly than the clocks out there and a
little bit of that also happens that the
earth is a little dimple that the earth
does and the way John Wheeler explained
Einstein's theory he says matter
distorts space and time and then matter
moves because of the distortion in space
and time and that's the best I can do
for you keep will do better okay
and in that theory there is also
gravitational waves and I want to show
you first a gravitational wave the and
the gravitational waves move at the
speed of light you've heard that already
and but there they are as you'll see in
a minute and what's this picture will
show is there a transfers wave there a
wave that the store space
perpendicular to the direction in which
the wave moves and so let me turn on
this little animation but before I do
that before you because you'll get sick
looking at it there you are right there
that's you in that little red square and
now I'll turn on the sound and animation
so you can see the wave coming by you
and you'll see some patterns in this
which are important for understanding
how we detected these things first of
all you'll notice that in let's say the
horizontal direction let's say it's
expanding but in the in the vertical
direction is contracting now any one
moment these things will flip but when
they there will be opposite motions
vertically and horizontally that's one
thing so that's a pattern that you you
exploit by the way you'll see where how
exploit that the other thing about it is
that that these are the objects that you
threw out into the space as the
gravitational wave comes through I
should have told you that so you look
here with not near you these let's say
these little masses they don't move very
much but the masses that are far away
from you they move a lot and that's a
picture of a constant strain along at
any one moment the change in distance
between objects is proportional to their
separation and that change in distance
divided by the separation is called the
strain and we will talk about that a lot
that's the quantity we measure but while
we actually measure the distance
separations but the quantity you
describe as the field corner he in the
theory is the strain and so let me tell
you a little bit of history now we
talked already about the theory being
developed about a hundred years ago in
1915 Einstein gave the world the general
theory of relativity is which was
described somewhat by that first picture
but then in 1916 he wrote a paper I'm
gonna have to drink something just to
bear with me stop forever in that theory
yeah later on he had a paper in 1916
where he describes a lot of things that
showed that it had a Newtonian limit and
he also shows that there are
gravitational waves in that 1916 paper
and the only reason why I bring this up
here is because of a very interesting
statement he made at the very end of the
paper he's described these things and
I'll talk to them about them in a minute
but he describes an equation which is up
here I want to tell you what that is it
says this is the strength of gravity of
gravitational waves and this is the
source of gravitational waves
oscillations and accelerations of matter
and he says something extremely
interesting
I haven't here in German but I'll read
it to you in English in any case one can
think of a that quantity will have a
practically vanishing value this is to
the end of that paper since you'll never
be able to measure this it's of no
consequence to science that's
effectively what he was saying and so he
makes a mistake in this paper but that
has nothing to do with it in 1918 he
corrects that
but I want to be I'll be presumptive a
little bit and we have I've asked the
people who will have the Einstein papers
to try to find what I'm about to show
you and they haven't found this on the
back of an envelope or in his notebooks
but I'm sure it's there somewhere
so let's I'm trying to give you a little
feel for why he made that statement and
you have to put yourself in the context
of 1915 1916 what did people know about
and what do they have and the first
thing you might have thought about is
two trains colliding how much
gravitational waves come out of that and
so let me give you a I won't use this is
not oh it's the only formula but I'll
explain it to you okay so here's the
strain that's H and this is the quantity
that when you want to estimate how much
strain you get from some kind of motion
is the a very simple estimation formula
it has the Newtonian constants in it the
mass of the objects and the distance you
are away from them and the velocity of
light squared that quantity G M divided
by RC squared is a very important
dimensionless quantity that we all know
and love what it is on the earth right
here it's about 10 to the minus 10 it's
very small you live in an extremely
small gravitational field even though
you may have to have any operations okay
but on the other hand what you'll hear
about from Barry and get is the places
where this number is closer to 1 it's
huge and those are places with no round
black holes and other places the
beginning of the universe and so forth
and the other quantity is V squared over
C squared this sort of a measure of how
much motion there is and that's velocity
to by the velocity of the object divided
by the velocity of light squared so that
quantity allows you to estimate H so
here for example for the two trains
coming together and by the way trains in
the United States don't go much faster
than this nowadays that that does not be
much advanced in that maybe in Europe
but not here not not in the United
States so let's pick 10 to the 5
kilograms but for the mass the velocity
about 100 killer kilometers per hour a
collision time of a third of a second or
so yeah and you have to be far enough
away so you're not looking at Newtonian
just a new induced
you have to go far away enough so that
you're looking at the radiation field
the field that carries these waves so
you have to go out a wavelength about
that's 300 kilometres and the H value
you get is 10 to the minus 42 and that
is truly impossible we can't even do
that now and that's why I stopped
probably made that statement so he might
have went very well looked at something
else I mean he knew about stars and he
knew about binary stars and these people
may not may did not know about the
galaxy the galaxy was something I was
being discovered at the time and so but
suppose he put numbers into that and he
takes stars that are going around each
other once once a day near the two stars
and suppose there are a distance of
about 10,000 light-years away they might
have guessed at that it might have been
30 I he probably didn't know exact
number for the size of the galaxy
because he didn't know about it and you
get an H value which isn't pretty small
it's 10 to minus 23 with a period of
half a day every half and every half a
day Pappa Perry takes less every half
day
you go through a thing that looks the
same so you get you look for
gravitational waves with a period of
half a day with a strength of 10 to
minus 23 that's what we would do now but
in his day he would have said well how
much energy is being taken away by
gravitational waves I'm not going to
describe that formula but if you look at
it that's what that gives and you would
get something like the following I'll
just say what the end result is here you
would have gotten that it would take 10
to the 13 years there 10 to the 13 years
for those stars in a telescope to look
like they were changing their business
their separation it's clearly hopeless
and so in both ways as an astronomical
thing and it's a technical thing I can
completely understand behind Stein now
it turns out in our epoch finally there
was a situation where that experiment
that I just described to you or the
measurement I just described you was
actually done but was done fairly
quickly and this is sort of a hundred
years later the technology has changed
and what we know about astronomy has
changed and this all becomes possible
and the thing is these are these are
Nobel Prize winners these two
this is a Russell Hulse who was a
graduate student at the time and Joe
Taylor and these were they they both
were the University of Massachusetts at
the time there but they went to
Princeton when because this was a major
discovery in egg got scooped up by all
these wonderful places and what they
discovered was a system of they didn't
know it but they discovered a pulsar
they were looking with a radio telescope
they looked and they used the Arecibo
telescope in fact the one that got in
the trouble in the big hurricane and and
they they listened and they heard a
thing going like that and it was going
in about 17 times a second that's the
pulsar and these are neutron stars stars
made completely of neutrons and they are
but they have the mass of the Sun and
they're about the size of Stockholm it's
really unbelievably dense thing and what
they heard is the pulse is coming from
that but they weren't going at a regular
rate sometimes I'm going a little faster
sometimes they're going a little slower
and it turns out when they mapped this
they kept looking at it they found that
for about four hours and this is a model
of it it turns out it turns out to be a
pair of neutron stars and they're going
around each other and when this pulsar
which is sending its pulses to the radio
telescope is moving toward the earth
which is over here it goes a little
faster from the Doppler effect and when
it's moving away from the earth it goes
a little slower and that's what they saw
and they map that and they watched it
through many many years this is time
over here and they saw in 1973 and they
kept watching it and what they noticed
is all sorts of all the wonderful tests
and general relativity were done by that
system but the one that was most telling
and most interesting for us today is
this one it's the one where they plot
the length of time it takes for the
orbit to complete every time you go
around once it's a period of the orbit
and it's being plotted here this is in
time epoch of the blocking the system
and this is the period of the orbit
getting shorter and shorter and shorter
these are minus signs over here and dot
the dots that are in here are their
measurements and the line that goes
through them is the prediction from the
1918 paper with a factor of two
correction that Einstein made of how
that system should lose energy due to
gravitational wave
so that was the very first indirect
measurement but the first measurement of
gravitational waves really profound
thing and it wasn't over okay so then
the next thing that happened and this is
again it happened because of technology
changes and what happened people began
to have the fact that you could think of
these very small strains and you now had
equipment as the technology change when
you could think of making a measurement
and the first person who actually
thought of that was Joe Weber he's right
here
he was a professor at the University of
Maryland that's him and there he is with
his invention the invention was by the
way also invention made together with
John Wheeler who was Kip's thesis
supervisor okay and what it is is a
great big bar it's like a monster so
that you could see how big it is some
things a man maybe bigger and what Joe
was hoping will happen is that a
gravitational wave will go through this
thing
stretch it momentarily and leave it and
leave it singing much like you hit it
with a hammer and there he is attaching
little strain gauges to the device so he
can hear that it was a electronic
equipment that was becoming available
and what happened is to his misfortune
he saw something and in fact he saw
something he made he made several of
these and put them in different places
in the United States he invented the
idea of using coincidence methods to do
this and he saw he had a system like
this in Chicago in the middle of the
United States one in Maryland and none
of them eight miles away from his office
you know in a golf course in Maryland
also and they saw he saw coincident
pulses and in 1969 he published the
paper which said he had discovered
gravitation waves and it turns out that
many many other people became interested
in doing that in science that's what
always happens a stunning result like
this can be tested by everybody else and
to his misfortune nobody else saw these
waves
nobody else saw these pulses and now we
know why people didn't see the pulses
the strength will fall and this is
something useful
to remember the strength that nuni and
he was able to measure with these things
a strain of about 10 to the minus 15 six
orders of magnitude bigger than what
ultimately you needed okay I'm sorry
okay I didn't realize that was happening
so what happened is people began to
think of other methods of doing this and
one method of doing it I'll describe
here is not with a bar but rather with a
thing which you really in the end was
more successful in making the real
measurements and that is to look at free
masses but like that picture of the
gravitational wave a mass over here and
you put another mass over there a goodly
distance away and you take and measure
the time it takes you want to measure
their separation as changing as the
gravitational wave comes by that's the
same picture of all those knots that I
showed you and so the idea is really
simple you take and have a light send
that and put a clock on those month put
clocks on the masses or we actually
let's start that way clock here clock
there on those masses send light
measured the moment when the light left
this mass and find out with another
clock over here
the time when it hits that mass that's
the way of measuring the distance
between those two masses and then let
the thing unfold and as a gravitational
wave comes along it'll change that time
because it's changing that distance it's
as simple as that now if you here's the
idea and this is as a way which a key
almost works and you don't you here you
have a laser and the beam splitter which
is a device that splits the light and
that's as in the picture I showed you
that would be the red square that I
showed you here is a distant mass and
that's a mirror and there's another
distant mass and remember the
gravitational wave is coming down and
what it'll do is is a stretch one of
these and compress this and it'll flip
then this one will stretch and that one
will compress and here is the way you
make that measurement which is
effectively timing light so with us but
I'll describe as it goes along
where it's red is light and we're
thinking of red lasers when they made
its picture but what you see is the way
these are the actual waves inside the
power of the light and where it's red is
where there's light if you do it right
and make the time here equal to the time
of light there you get no light going to
the photo detector that's the idea and
so if you will show that's for the photo
tech now when you move these masses one
out the other one in you'll see that
there is light when the motion makes it
so the path links are no longer equal
and that is in fact the basis for the
entire experiment because it's no more
complicated than that
the big problem comes you have to do it
extremely well and here is how well kick
comes on the scene I met kit in 1975
when he and I met in Washington DC he
was thinking at that time he was giving
testimony to a committee and he and I
spent the night talking about what kind
of experiments are interesting to do and
he was at that time had already the most
successful group I think in the country
doing theoretical gravitation and he was
hoping to start a group hab Caltech
start a group in in in experimental work
and what we came on is that Kipp at that
meeting he and I talked about that
ultimately there's this technique that
we were just talking about here would be
a good thing for Caltech to work on and
but he told us something then already
that you couldn't just do it in this
haphazard way that was it had to be done
and he was one of the first to tell us
that if you want to get in the business
you had to measure h's or these strains
tell two changes in length divided by
the length of 10 to the minus 21 I think
this is Kip about that time he'll tell
us if I'm wrong yeah he's agreeing okay
and the big thing is that if you make
something and now we're getting on
mixing times but that's too bad suppose
if you go to something as long as 4
kilometers you then and you do the a
little bit of arithmetic that's
associated with that you find out that
you have to measure distances at the
ends that motion of 10 to the minus 18
meters that's something like a
thousandth the size of a nucleus of an
atom that's very hard
and here is the challenge that this
threw at us if you want to use light to
make that measurement light has a
wavelength of about ten to the minus six
meters you have to go a million times
times a million million times a million
more sensitive to the wavelength of
light to get into business that's what
he was telling us if you want to use
light to do this but then you had
another problem which an nhien turned
out to be much harder than that problem
and that is even though you might have
made a wonderful measure method of
measuring things their position with
light the things that you're looking at
I'm not going to be standing still well
they're gonna be kicked around by
everything in the world especially the
world and because you and I are sitting
right here where we're being jiggled
around by the ground by about one micron
at least a few microns so ten minus six
so he got another factor of a million
times a million and that one was a
really hard one and so here is the
things that went on and now the rest of
this is really about people because
people are critical to getting that
factor of a billion and a billion
building us a pile European billion ten
is six times in this second so a guy who
really helped a lot in this thing was a
guy named who was not so heralded as a
man named Pirani who was a theorist who
told us yes it was possible to measure
gravitational waves with things freely
floating around that was a big big
challenge there was a lot of worry about
whether you could ever extract any kind
of measurable signal from gravitational
waves and he showed us that there was an
in the invariant way didn't depend on
the coordinates that you use of showing
that a gravitational wave was mu was
moving the masses changing the space and
that's of course exploited in this and
several ideas and these are all people
who were critical to it some of the
gimmicks some of the tricks that you
need and some of the tricks were first
exploited in a small prototype at MIT
but it was not a very good prototype but
the ideas I won't describe that picture
anymore to say the following thing we
knew already that God used lasers you
couldn't use just one a very weak light
source
the other thing you needed to is you're
somehow had to make the light to go more
than once back and forth you have to
bounce the light back and forth and you
had to do tricks to get around the noise
and that would tricks you have to
modulate the light you have to use all
the cunning tricks yeah and the other
thing you had to do is you couldn't put
the masses right on the ground
you had to somehow float them so the
ground and motion would not make a
signal so large that you couldn't see
the gravitational waves and all those
tricks were tried in this prototype but
the people who really did it right and
who actually demonstrated to all of us
that this was possible was the group
that's up on top here and you'll notice
that this is the group that was in
joshing and Max Planck group and here is
Heights Billings he was a guy who worked
on bars with Weber was severely
disappointed the whole group after they
did it they showed they were one of the
first and most accurate to show that
Weber's experiments were not right and
so they were fishing around what would
be the next thing to do and instead of
quitting they decided they were gonna go
into this interfering metric method of
doing this and here they are and each
one of them the one who's in the room
here is Albert reader he's somewhere in
this room I haven't seen him but
unfortunately there most of them are
dead if a bath of Engler is still alive
and Klaus nope and we have celebrated
her her name is now ingrained in the
apparatuses we have for a particular
trick of making it so you can see the
fringes better my Vega was deeply
involved in that hanging all the masses
not just the mirrors hanging everything
we didn't think of that
just hang everything you have to hell
with it learn how to do interferometry
with things that aren't suspensions
forget about it how difficult it is and
the same thing with a really good he was
also advocating that and his role on
shilling who invented all sorts of ideas
of how to get the vent how to get toward
that factor of 10 to the 12 in in
insensitivity he also invented along
with Ron River will talk about in a
minute the idea of power recycling so
then there was another group so they
were but what did they do we will talk
about a little more but they built a
three meter prototype much faster than
the people in MIT did and they showed
that a lot of the ideas were right they
also showed that a lot of the things
thinking I've been done ahead of that
had mistakes in it that we hadn't
thought it through properly which was
very important especially the scattering
light scattering and something they
discovered well here's the other group
that was very important in this
development is the group at Glasgow and
here's Ron driver
Ron driver was then later came to
Caltech and work there and we'll talk a
little about that in a minute but Jim
Huff was his student and here's Brian
Mears invented a very a critical idea
that has now become important in these
interferometers that I'll get to that in
a minute
but to add another mirror in a very
unlikely place and Harry Ward developed
the ideas of how one might align systems
like this and that group was all at the
beginning they invented a whole bunch of
new ideas also and that group was
critical in this business of going to
the 10 to the 12 in the position
sensitivity and the things that actually
then followed this were instruments they
made more prototypes were built Caltech
when Ron griever went to Caltech and
Stan Whitcomb was hired what happened
they built this instrument I wish I had
more pictures of it and more of the
pictures of people but they built this
40 meter instrument and that's still
operating that 40 meter instrument was a
testbed for the things that went into
the LIGO into the actual legal and here
is a other experiment I was done by the
German group and the German group with
David shoemaker who was an import from
the United States at the time and they
did they built the 30 after they got
done with their three metre prototype
they built the 30 meter Trump 30 meter
prototype and showed that the scaling
laws worked
I was absolutely critical and they then
in fact make a lovely statement in here
at the end you can't read this but I'll
tell you they got to the past the
sensitivity of the bars the best bars
they did better with this instrument
then you could do with rubber bars and
that was extremely important statement
because that made everybody say aha this
is the wave of the future and if you're
now gonna build something big you're
gonna have to do it with this car
something that's going to detect this
kind of thing here's the group at MIT
it's a little later
reason why I'd like this is because it
has some of the people who are now
leaders of this thing and there there
were young people there
nergis mavala love of allah and then
there's there's a this peter's official
right there and in the back is brian
brian lance and this is mike zuker who
was a child tech working on a 40 meter
he came to MIT this was after a while it
turned out those two groups became sort
of completely interchangeable and that
was a lot of things were done there i
won't go into all of them all
preparatory to what i'm about to show
you so this is out of time syrians it
should really belong in Barrie's talk
but I have to show it because he wants
to show other things too this is
actually the interferometer that a cue
made the detection and let me I'm not
gonna walk you through except to show
you where some of the things you already
know exist
here's a laser again there's the beam
splitter
here's that distant mirror and there's
that distant mirror
here's the gravitational wave coming
down the things that have been added to
it are these two masses this one and
that one that makes it so that this
becomes something called a fabry-perot
cavity it's a way effectively of
bouncing the light back and forth about
300 times and in here about 300 times
and then here is the photo detector and
again you operate it in such a manner
that there no light goes to the photo
detector when there's no gravitational
wave and then here's the idea that both
Ron Brielle and chilling had you put
another mirror which you haven't seen
before
between the laser and the beam splitter
and what that mirror does I will just
describe what it does and I'll show you
is it takes the light that isn't going
to the photo detector that comes out of
laser goes into your arm is not going to
the voter detector it would normally go
back to the laser but you make it so
you've bounced it back into the end of
the interferometer and build up the
light inside the interferometer for that
reason and that makes it as though you
had a very much more powerful laser a
very clever idea
then here's Brian Mears idea and that is
that you put another mirror which is not
this is not immediately something that
everybody can capture because you need
to know a lot more than I told you why
this works so well but what does it do
by putting a mirror between the detector
and the beam splitter it makes it so you
can Taylor
the response of the interferometer you
can make it have different shapes make
it have so that it's more sensitive at
certain frequencies and stuff like that
and that's called this is called a power
recycling mirror and that's called a
signal recycling mirror and that's an
important part of advanced LIGO so this
is the advanced LIGO detector okay now
that is the technology of the how do you
make the light get that factor of 10 to
the 12 we're not quite done with the
technology of how you make them ground
motion small enough but first let's talk
about how you build build up begin to
build up the idea that you don't want to
do just prototypes you would like to
actually build a detector and that
happened in about 1988 II know that we
began to think hard about how might how
expensive how might you build a systems
and actually could detect something we
were driven to that for many many
reasons it was hard for students to at
least with MIT to keep working on
something which didn't have a physics
result had had only an engineering
result and I don't know at Caltech it
was different they had a different
attitude about this but the thing is
that what we began to think about is
really we asked the NSF if we could do
and we were also encouraged by the NSF
and we'll get to that at the very end to
make an industrial study with industry
to find out where could you place a
thing that was big enough and we thought
of five kilometer arms maybe even ten
kilometer arms and could you get the
lasers and how would you make the vacuum
system and all the stuff that goes on
that if you want to convert a thing on a
tabletop into something very big and
there was a study done and that two
people here were quite central to this
Peter Slauson who helped in that he was
a postdoc would come from Princeton and
Stan Whitcomb who had been brought on by
Caltech and he want to be part of this
same study and this is called the Blue
Book study and it did it it did that a
little bit later and with very
significant differences because during
that time between 1983 and 1989
we did a bad thing we had Rhonda River
and Ray Weiss trying to run a big
project with the help of Kip Thorne it
was hopeless and it was noticed by a
committee that met in 1986 that had been
asked to look at this whole field and
that committee had been started by
Richard Garwin a very significant
personage in American science who said
look if you're gonna persist with this
you better have a summer study and that
summer study said look it's a wonderful
experiment don't all back build two of
them make them on the long length they
said everything right and they said you
can't do it with that crazy bunch we're
running it okay and said get yourself a
director so we got a director and that
director was Ravi vote and Ravi vote
guided us through writing a proposal
which was really a textbook it's a
beautiful proposal it cost us a lot of
time it's a first real document that
showed a lot of the techniques and how
it might build this and costed it
properly and what happened is that that
proposal became a joint proposal of
Caltech and MIT and there's one very
elegant thing that Rabi vote did among
others he did something which was he
coupled in the process of thinking about
this project
he coupled an engineer if we had an
engineer and we didn't have enough of
them and Barry later when he took this
over realized that but we had some
engineers but we had a lot of scientists
and the idea was couple and engineer who
knew how to count money but also knew
how what was practical with a mad
scientist who want to make sure you
didn't compromise the experiment and
couple them together so that they design
something and estimated something which
was going to be both realistic as well
as you're able to do the experiment and
that was a very good experience I can
show you only some of the people here
who were in the who did this and they
well you recognize something there's Ron
there's Kip and then there's a chief
engineer at the time bill Althouse
here is an engineer who stayed with the
project and then I couldn't get a
picture of the vacuum engineer at the
time who was doing this now that is
valid more and here's Larry Jones and
Larry Jones was tagged with me and we
helped design
that being big the big beam tubes and so
forth and so this was a very important
moment in the history of like oh let me
go quickly more back to the science a
little bit or the technology and that is
this is the kind of thing that evolved
when in that proposal we want to show
people what limited the performance of a
gravitational wave detector this is in
fact a plot of the things that limited
the verse first detector very will show
you the evolution of that detector but I
just want to walk you through some of
the things in here which are still
important what this is is frequency in
other words this one Hertz 100 Hertz
that's an important region 10 kilohertz
over here here is a strain of about 10
to the minus 23 per bandwidth I'm sorry
this is a dig you using here you're
using spectra so if you want to go back
to what I was telling you you have to
multiply this number by the square root
of the frequency that's a detail for
those of you who want to follow but
that's not important what I want to show
you is what was limiting this detector
at high frequencies is this line and
that's the amount of light power you had
at low frequencies it was limited by
something else but I want to continue
this because this is important for kips
talk this is part of what's called the
quantum limit the amount of light you
use to tell the position of the mass is
if you use more light here having more
photons you can bring that down but you
pay a price for that over here is
another piece of that same noise which
is called the radiation pressure and
that is if you use more light
you push on the masses and there's noise
in that light that pushes the masses
around and many of you have led quantum
mechanics know that this something
called the Heisenberg microscope this is
just the Heisenberg microscope
macroscopic okay when you try to measure
better the position of something you
impart more noise momentum to it and
that's what these this curve says and
this is something we're now battling and
you'll hear more about that from Kipp
and from Barry the other noise is in
this thing for example how well can you
get rid of the ground noise and at the
time when we were designing this this
limit is the noise that shakes the
ground
there's seismic noise and that makes a
limited low frequencies
then there's here this limit is the fact
that everything is a room temperature
and when everything is at room
temperature every surface is shaking new
to phonons through the sound waves in
the sound waves that are generated by
the just the fact that there's there's
an energy in the in the tenor in the
heat
so that's thermal noise and here are
some things that still plague us all
right here is the thing that made it
cost so much money if you had a vacuum
and was only as good as a certain value
and say this is a value that you could
get moderately easily that would be a
limit for a detector that would be
better than this and I have failed to
tell you something that proposal in 1989
proposed a two-stage procedure
it's proposed we build one that we know
how to build now or almost know how to
build now and another one we hope to
build in the future and that would need
much better vacuum than this and back
down here and that getting that whole
assembly together making the vacuum good
enough was an expensive proposition but
we have we succeeded with that in a very
unique and interesting way and so what
remains as the nor is is this one right
here this is a very important noise and
that's the last thing I'll show you in
this picture you'll notice it gets worse
and worse and worse the lower the
frequency and that is a noise which we
have to contend with and it's the noise
that we will can have to continue to
contend with with as they're two noises
in this we have to continue to Kenneth
this is one of them and the other one is
the one I already told you about which
is the quantum noise but this one is
something which is not easily thought
about always by people you have the
ground shaking and that's fine but when
the ground shakes there's another piece
associated with that there a wave
traveling in the ground causes the
density of the ground to change and
let's say this bunch of flowers is the
mirror and here are these waves coming
by and as it as it moves here's this
compression going on in the ground like
that and as the compression goes by this
it's a little higher density over here
that pulls the flowers over to this
earth to the ground that's a force on
the mirror that's plain Newtonian
gravity and that's the noise waves are
their acceleration there but the density
changes in the ground make a change in
the force on the mirror and we have to
contend with that
and also the ven see changes in the
atmosphere and there's the Hungarian two
groups that has joined LIGO as think of
thought about methods of measuring the
barometric pressure of carefully enough
so that you can measure that so those
are noises that are still with us and we
have to learn how to get around them and
that's one of the reasons why people
propose the Lisa experiment which Kip
will talk well I think yeah Kip will
talk about so all right that's sort of a
little bad quick guide through all the
things that contaminate the
gravitational wave signal the last thing
I want to quickly say and this is really
an Berry's part of this presentation
that says it's what we did to make the
final steps in getting rid of the ground
noise not the gravity gradient noise but
just the acceleration and this was a
contribution to LIGO for the advanced
LIGO done by the group in Scotland and
this is a well this is a very elegant
suspension here's a spring that's
attached to the ground and there's a
mass and this is a suspension and if you
wiggle a suspension quickly that you
hang it the thing you hang it from them
doesn't move so you do that once then
you do it once again you do it once
again you do it four times and here's
that very precious mirror that's gonna
be reflecting the light and that four
stage suspension is a critical part of
LIGO and especially a critical part that
we made a detection but even more
important as far as I'm concerned is
this thing which is much too complicated
to tell you about but I'll tell you what
it does it's an active system that gets
rid of the ground noise and you have a
lot of experience with that in in your
hearing I don't know how many of you use
these noise-canceling headphones I'm
sure that people here yeah okay it's the
same principle what you do is you put a
very sensitive seismometer on a platform
and measure the motion of the platform
and then what you do is you push on that
platform to get rid of the signal in the
seismometer that's the same thing you do
with the headphones that the headphones
listen to the sounds like are coming in
they generate a sound that's the
opposite sign in the headphones and you
don't hear the outside world you only
hear the music and that's on the other
part of the headphone that's how that
works it's the same idea it's an active
system and that is absolutely could
to us and that's was that was developed
both people I go and Stanford University
okay now people again I want to give
this special credit to Richard Isaacs
who is in the audience and I know he's
gonna be shirking and when his name is
mentioned but I want to tell you what he
did for us first of all he was a
first-class scientist in this business
to begin with and he wrote a paper quite
early in in the sixties where he showed
a thing that was very controversial at
the time that gravitational waves
actually carried energy away from a
source that was heavily debated a lot of
people thought it was just a coordinate
problem but he showed there was actually
energy leaving a gravitational wave
source and here is and what he did he
became the discipline chief for gravity
at the NSF and he convinced his boss
Martha Marcel Barton at this crazy idea
that we all had really had merit and he
did it at a time when it was not so easy
to do that we didn't have the technology
in hand and we didn't know what sources
were gonna see and he had to sell this
idea to his boss and he did a
magnificent job of it then he sold the
whole agency on this okay and that's
something which is spectacular without
him this would not have worked and these
are some of the people who were
influenced by that and I want to say
something special about these are
directors of the NSF which were critical
to our development rich Isaacson was
actually deeply mixed up with Eric block
with his boss and Eric Bloch was an
engineer and and I the same thing
happened in MIT the engineers were the
first to recognize and then at MIT that
this might have some value the
electrical engineers around me it wasn't
so much the physicist and so he had the
idea that this was exactly the right
thing for the NSF to get into something
very risky but had a tremendous payoff
and so Eric block pushed it and then
when things really began to happen and
there were people who didn't like the
idea that LIGO was beginning to use
money from the NSF there were people in
the Astronomy community that actually
resisted it you can read the newspapers
as well as I and Walter Massey who was
had at that time a little later actually
told these people who were very
influential no no we're gonna do this
because it's the right thing for the
country and it's the right thing for the
NSF and it was quite a struggle and he
was a magnificent person for doing that
and then to make it all happen the head
of the NSF at that time and this is in
Barry's epic was Neil Lane and Neil Lane
helped NSF figure out how to go to
Congress and say look the NSF needs a
line item for big projects that hadn't
done big projects before but that's what
we need to do and so there was something
new invented and that's how you get
money you don't go to Congress
complaining you never go to Congress and
complaining stop this and give it to us
that's the wrong way to do it what you
do is here is a good idea why don't you
try to fund this and the idea was the
NSF has all the science we sometimes
need to build big projects and we and
and we need big chunks of money
periodically
and that's still in the NSF budget line
and Neil Lane was actually critical in
doing that and now last slide is this is
when the project as far as I'm concerned
actually got started because then there
enough people were brought in you had
finally we had somebody who understood
that it took more than a fence as a
skunkworks to make things happen
Barry came we were lucky that Barry came
partly because an unlock of the high
energy physicist the superconducting
supercollider got killed by I think was
quite clear it was Clinton I killed it
and he brought Jerry Sanders who's in
the audience who as a project manager
was a superb project manager he then
hired more people thank God he hired ala
Albert Lazzarini who's also in the
audience and Denis coin as a chief
engineer and he has been with the
project for a long long time he's now
doing something very interesting
difference in this and what was happened
is that Stan with him was brought back
from industry though it was already
under Robbie but he really was made and
became sort of the chief scientist of
LIGO and I am done thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
okay thank you very much you got every
chance to cut my plate there also
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so professor buys postman who
really laid the foundations for much of
the design of this gravitational wave
detector and the next speaker then
professor bearish he was a scientific
leader who managed to scale up the LIGO
project in a stepwise fashion reaching
the advanced LIGO which was really the
facility that managed to detect the
gravitational waves so please for the
merit
so I guess everybody knew before they
were here today that this is a very long
story and we're now to the beginning of
the next part of the long story I'm
gonna try hard to stay on time
there's 21 years more to go after after
the story that you just heard which took
a long time so I'm gonna pick up the
story in 1994 and in 1994 was when we
received for the first time project
funding to actually build something
which is the LIGO detector with all the
responsibility of getting tens of
millions of dollars a year for 20 years
and defending it during a period where
we saw nothing during that whole time so
the first thing that people should
realize is that the National Science
Foundation not only took the risk that
Ray mentioned in taking on this project
doing the R&D and so forth but after it
was taken on they had to defend a
project with all the risks that it had
for 20 years with essentially no results
we basically set various limits because
we didn't see anything but for no
results and so we're probably indebted
more to the NSF and one can imagine in
taking on such a project we organized it
by a collaboration between Caltech and
MIT and that shouldn't be lost in the
story because we now have a thousand
scientists around the world but we have
at the center of all this what we call
the like like a laboratory and the LIGO
laboratory is the group that actually
has built and made the detector work the
responsibility for the detector is
Caltech and MIT and we've organized that
as a project we have about a hundred and
fifty technicians scientists and so
forth the scientists in this group do
their science in what we call the LIGO
science collaboration but the instrument
has been built by us the president
director is Dave right see whose
pictures up there
and the deputy directors Albert
Lazzarini and they're running it today
while we're doing all this fantastic
science and earlier after I was director
was Jay marks who led it during the
crucial period when we took on advanced
LIGO next in about 1997 we realized that
the Caltech and MIT collaboration didn't
bring all the elements we were going to
need to succeed with this project and
certainly not all the scientific ones so
we created what people have heard about
today and that is the LIGO scientific
collaboration bringing in talents
varying from experts and lasers to
experts on at now artificial
intelligence in order to take the whole
breadth of talents they can be brought
to this incredibly difficult problem and
pull it together that's grown from what
started as tens of people in the
collaboration run by Ray who I appointed
at that point at the time to run the
collaboration to a collaboration now
that's very democratic with elected
officers and is read run presently by
david shoemaker by gabriela gonzalez
during the period where we made the
first detection before that by Dave
Wright see who now is running the
laboratory and Peter sawsan who you
heard about was after after ray this is
a magnificent success of international
collaboration of the ability to bring in
the talents that we need whether its
technical whether its data analysis
whether it's theoretical together
working together side by side we have 18
countries involved in LIGO more than a
hundred institutions and about 1,200
collaborators of which a thousand were
with us long enough that they were
credited with authorship on our
discovery paper the interferometers
themselves are organized with some
critical people that have run it from
the beginning
we've had somebody who's at these sites
that
distant and not close to a city and run
by two people originally fred rob and
mark coles who later went to the
National Science Foundation and
presently by Mike Landry who newly took
over Hanford at the Hanford Observatory
and Joe Giambi in Livingston so if you
visit either those laboratories that's
who you see and they're remote one in
distant Louisiana far from any city and
the other on do a reservation in eastern
Washington just to see just to show you
what things look like and the real
hardware this is a picture of LIGO if
you walked into the big hall where this
is the vertex that Ray showed where the
light then goes out in two directions
this big thing here are called gate
valves they allow us to preserve the
fantastic vacuum that Ray talked about
that we need to while we work and evolve
the instrument these instruments that
you look at here aren't quite as simple
as what ray showed and part of that is
building in enough flexibility all these
ports and all the ways of getting in so
that from the beginning we understood
that if we're ever gonna detect
gravitational waves what we built at the
beginning wasn't going to probably make
it so we had to be able to evolve the
instrument and in ways that we weren't
sure how to do it so we as much as
possible we asked the NSF for more
funding at the beginning and made as
flexible an instrument as we possibly
could we build it by the end of maybe
1999 we had it built and then we started
making it work and this picture kind of
illustrates how we approach the next 15
years
we basically this is the same curve that
was shown by Ray where it's limited on
the left side by the shaking of the
earth on this side by the amount of
light and in between by the noise on
these test masses that we talked about
and better sensitivity is the bottom of
the plot it's the same scale that Ray's
showed
this is the frequency band that's
available to us to look for
gravitational waves it says it's the
audio band where the earth is the
quietest each each curve here is
basically subsequently a different time
so our strategy basically was to turn
this on it was that whatever sensitivity
it was this isn't very sensitive look
our wounds look at what we did wrong
what was limiting it take time off run
it again and it evolved to a better
curve a better curve a better curve this
is about the first five years of the
detector we kept doing this for ten
years
at each at each time we would search for
gravitational waves each time we
wouldn't find gravitational waves each
time we would have a better limit
because this was better on how well we
knew they didn't appear and so we wrote
a series of papers but they basically
were null papers during that period
along the way we got to the point where
we were as good as we had proposed
except maybe a little bit at the low
frequencies and this that's this curve
here so this is the initial detector
that we were funded for by the National
Science Foundation on the same kind of
graph as good as we could we knew very
early as Ray had indicated that we
wanted to do this in two stages that we
could incrementally improve things but
only so far without making some major
changes so we had done the detailed Rd
necessary to develop the techniques and
the apparatus itself the detailed
designs that would go into a second
generation detector and that was what we
called advanced LIGO interestingly we
called it like o2 but the NSF in their
wisdom decided that we were sneaky ly
talking about like a 1 2 3 4 so they
asked us to change the name and it
became advanced LIGO with advanced LIGO
we then build it between 19 2010 and
2013 or so and started turning it
we could we basically had learned a lot
so we turned it on a lot faster than we
had the initial LIGO getting nearer
design sensitivity by 2015 it started to
work well enough so that it was better
than what we had built for initial LIGO
and that is shown here the key people by
the way for advanced LIGO some of the
key people I show over here Dennis Coyne
who was shown earlier has stayed with us
as our chief engineer and was the
engineer responsible for the fantastic
engineering that goes into advanced LIGO
David shoemaker who's running the
collaboration now was basically the the
main scientist responsible for advanced
LIGO and Peter official for the
incredible optics that we use and the
way the interferometer works itself and
two people one in each laboratory who
have been the most responsible for the
making this thing actually work in the
field and so we started to make it work
and the two detectors are in the two
different colors here and what they
indicate is that despite the fact that
they're physically in very different
locations so basically in design and as
long as we do the same thing at the same
time they were essentially identically
to each other at this point
this had improved about a factor of
three beyond where we were in in initial
LIGO our goal was to improve things a
factor of 10
this is improving the sensitivity a
factor of 3 and what you realize is that
the sensitivity tells you how far out
you look in the universe so if we
increase the sensitivity a factor of 3
we actually improve how much of the
universe we're looking at by the cube of
that because that's the volume that
scanned so an improvement of a factor of
3 basically gave us the ability to do
what we had done an initial LIGO or more
in one year what we could have done in
27 years with initial aegyo so we
decided not to go all the way to here
but have a similar strategy to what we
had an initial LIGO and use this as a
first search because we had improved the
concept for how we treat low frequencies
which was described by Ray the
improvement as say 40 Hertz was actually
a factor of a hundred shown here a
factor of a hundred is cubed in terms of
the sensitivity we get so we were really
a million times better than we were an
initial aegyo and that answers a
question that's often asked to us how
could we turn this thing on and after a
few days which is what happened make a
discovery when we had run it for ten
years before that are almost ten years
and it's really this factor of a million
so we turned on advanced LIGO and made
that improvement again this is just a
picture to emphasize that the big
improvement that made this detection may
be the take-home message if you want to
tell anybody why and how we made the
detection was the improvement in this
nice quadruple and fancy suspension
system developed at Glasgow and the
suspected the isolation from the earth
by seismic isolation from the earth by a
set of essentially shock absorbers and
these active seismic feedback systems
that Ray mentioned that by the way have
two reason they're how so hard it has to
be done directionally differently than
the earphones and the airplane we have
to know where the earth is shakiness
what direction and correct for it
and that makes the system quite a bit
more difficult we turned on and a few
days later this is what we found so this
was September 14 2015 21 years after we
received project funding in 1994 not
what my fantasies
most of us for what we first see I would
have expected if I thought about what we
would see that we start to see hints of
gravitational waves where our detector
wasn't quite sensitive enough yet to
make it definitively and then we keep
working in the future and making it more
sensitive
we were lucky instead we of course made
big improvements but we immediately saw
a signal that stood out and looked very
much like you draw to show somebody what
we were doing this is two different
traces one of them at the laboratory in
eastern Washington Hanford Laboratory
and one in Louisiana and they should
look essentially alike you'll notice the
left-hand side is strain the word that
ray used and the scale is the scale he
also showed 10 to the minus 21 so the
scale that we were detecting and got to
the sensitivity to detect and also the
scale that had more or less been
predicted by the range of sources that
we talked about was 10 to the minus 21
and that turned out to be after all
these years right and these are the two
traces if I take the two traces and plot
them on top of each other and slide one
slightly from the other one by seven 6.9
milliseconds then they sat essentially
right on top of each other as you can
see here and the difference between the
time between the two I'll point out in a
minute gives us information that's
crucial especially for the future so
those are the two detection by the way
we made a decision in 1994 finally we
had to make the decision in 1994 how to
orient these two detectors relative to
each other they can't be exactly the
same because the earth curves by 16
degrees between Livingston Louisiana and
Hanford Washington but there was a
rather large debate whether we take the
two l-shaped detectors and make them
parallel to each other or rotate them by
45 degrees the reason you would rotate
by 45 degrees is it gives you the
ability to extract more physics that is
there's a polarization in these
electromagnetic in these gravitational
waves just like for electromagnetic
waves so the argument to rotate them is
exactly that the argument to put them in
parallel is what I showed you here that
we could put one on top of the other we
did it one on top of the other in
conservatism and of course is what made
one event so convincing that we could
put one on top of the other but we
couldn't tell the polarization
information that has come and I'll talk
in a minute by adding a third detector
that is oriented separately from us
that's the Virgo detector and that start
has started to give us information on
the polarization we detected this event
in September of 2015
did we immediately know it was
gravitational waves not really most of
us are some of us at least had deep
worries how we might be mistaken how we
might be fooling ourselves or how we
might be being fooled those two
questions basically in translation were
that we turned on a new apparatus and in
turning on a new apparatus maybe it
could generate some sort of shaky
signals but they weren't real and in
order to test that you have to run it
for some period of time we calculated
how long that had to be and it was
basically a month in a month's time we
could look at all the bins of time in
the to correlate them together and see
what the probability is that you could
get any sort of signal like this in the
detector and that's calculated to be a
magic number in physics when you believe
something which we call five sigma all
are the probabilities less than one in
some hundreds of thousands of years so
basically that was the first thing the
second problem was maybe somehow we were
being fooled by somewhat mischievous
people our person who has superposed
this on the data
and we just looked at the data and it
really wasn't there that again had to be
studied in great detail by his following
the idea was the following the data
comes together at Caltech and from that
time on goes around the world in fact
this first event was seen first in
Germany it was the middle of the night
in the States and the data comes
together once it's together you could
imagine somebody superposing
an event on top of the data to resolve
that we have to take it back to the
laboratories where we had traced the
signals and what they recorded along the
way and that required another study
which took about a month so by a middle
of October I think we had really
confidence that we had made this
discovery we spent maybe another month
seeing how well it fits general
relativity spent in another month
writing it up in great detail writing it
up in a way that we thought could be
read by the world and not just by
experts in the field arguing about
whether it should be called an
observation or a discovery and things
like that with a thousand people
weighing in and you can imagine
somehow making that converge was a
problem we finally were ready to submit
this to Physical Review Letters our
choice of where to publish this by early
December of 2015 we were about a week
late because we were arguing too long on
which adjectives to use in the paper and
at that point Physical Review Letters
who had agreed that they would allow us
to make the article longer than the
standard article and that they would
review it especially both very secretly
and quickly informed us that we were now
too close to Christmas and they couldn't
do it so we held the article until
January and interestingly our second
event which I show now came on December
26th so when we announced this event on
February of 20 2016 we knew but we
didn't yet bring that
public that we also had a second event
so it's convincing as the first of that
was we all had a second event it looks
very different you can see this has many
many oscillations it's smaller but we
detect it as well because there's so
many oscillations that's a reflection of
the fact that they're lighter the two
black holes that are colliding it's also
black hole collisions this graph here
just illustrates it's the so-called
chirp graph this is basically time going
this way frequency going this way it
gets louder as the frequency goes up and
this is getting this so-called chirp
that we described as a signal the second
one which is weaker but in there longer
so we are able to pull out the signal is
down here but if we look at basically
the low frequencies that weren't
available to us until we made the big
improvement in the suspension and the
isolation system both of these signals
were enabled by making those
improvements at low frequencies of
course we've kept running we finished
that first data run with these two
events in January of 2016 and at that
point we changed things fix things in
the same spirit that I presented our
activities through the period of initial
LIGO and we started a second day to run
which may be for most of us we expect it
couldn't possibly be as exciting as what
we saw in the first day to run that
turned out to be wrong as I'll show you
in the second date of run I show here
that we haven't analyzed all the data
yet we haven't made all our reports yet
but this is where we are today we
basically have reported five
observations of probably black holes one
of them we don't call a black hole just
because it's further away and doesn't
give us quite the five Sigma's
significance as a single event but
otherwise it appears to be like the
others so we have a set of events
we start to let us look at distributions
of the alignments of spins the masses of
them and the difference in how long they
are is the difference in how much their
masses are and so forth so the fifth one
here actually has a different
significance that's this one here the
dates are the 17th the 8th month the
14th day in 2017 so just this last
August so this last August we detect an
event that at the same time was detected
for the first time also in the Virgo
detector in Italy the Virgo detector is
very much like like oh I don't have time
to show some interesting differences in
how they approach the problem but it
basically has similar sensitivity once
it's not fully operational will have
similar sensitivity this was begun by
two scientists in parallel with the
efforts that were described by Ray
Elaine brulee and Alberto Giotto and in
the present day run a little bit like us
having a laboratory where the director
is Farini Frederico Farini and the
spokesman who I hope I think is here
today is yo van der brand from Holland
and it's very near Pisa in Italy it's
not just this confidence which of course
matters that somebody independent sees
the same thing that's great and at this
point we don't really need that we're
pretty convinced that we're seeing
gravitational waves but and we were in
competition for twenty years I think to
see who could see gravitational waves
first but it gives us new information
and that's shown here with just the
first detectors we were able to locate
even on the first event that it came
from the southern hemisphere and we knew
to some number six or seven hundred
square degrees where it came from and
the various events are shown here
and how well we could tell where they
came from before we turned on the Virgo
detector the veer go to texture once
it's on because it gives us
triangulation and we're with the signal
they see compared to ours where we take
the time difference in the arrival time
with the different detectors and the
difference in the signal because the
antenna patterns are somewhat different
gave us this signal down here and you
can see that we now can locate with the
addition of Virgo the location on the
sky where a gravitational event came
very accurately this is something we've
always wanted to do and luckily for us
this happened just in time and I'll show
you that in a minute first let me
reflect on what we found so far seeing
five events we've seen where this is
mass and this is just the time passing
the number of events these are each skim
bollocky ly two black holes coming
together making a heavier black hole
they're all up here on the plot where
this is mass what was expected was black
holes that would be down here so we
immediately something we've always
thought using gravitational waves would
see different phenomenon that are seen
in electromagnetic radiation and what we
saw was large black holes they're not
expected just qualitatively the reason
is the progenitor or the heavier object
that makes these black holes is supposed
to be a heavy star that decays and makes
a black that dies and collapses and
makes a heavy makes a black hole there
aren't we believe very heavy heavy
enough stars to make these very easily
there has to be either a special place
in the universe where it's low enough
metallicity or doesn't have heavy
elements around them so it can live
longer or dense clusters or primary
primordial production that made these
black holes and that's our next problem
like all these problems in physics is
where do these black holes come from
there are handles on it we
to get more information on the spins on
the orientations on the distributions
and to be able to resolve that the
second thing that has come out of the
very first events is test of general
relativity this is a graph where we just
put in a form that would be
qualitatively are different from general
relativity just to test it not a
particularly one limit of that is to
look at the physical place where you
would have connected to the transmission
of gravitational waves what we call a
graviton very much like for
electromagnetic waves we have a photon
or for particle physics there's all the
particles we a graviton if it existed
does not exist in Einstein's theory
could have a mass and what we're able to
do is if it had a mass it changes the
detailed shape of that trace that we
looked at and we're able to say already
just a based on these very first
observations that if there is such a
mass it's less than 7 10 to the minus 23
electron volts over C squared so those
are tests the next was a rather
fortunate coincidence we got there go
into our into our system working
together two weeks before this happened
in later in August by the way we were
scheduled to turn off at the end of
August so this happened fortunately just
before we turned off well for the first
time we saw a second kind of event the
merger of a binary neutron star system
instead of a binary neutron star system
instead of a blackhole system what is a
neutron star again ray mention neutron
stars it comes from the collapse of a
star also we believe but it's a dense
it's dense nuclear matter instead of a
black hole if it's dense nuclear matter
if we have two objects going around each
other it has all kinds of nuclear if
in addition to just the general
relativistic merger and this is nuclear
physics and extreme conditions and we
can then see all kinds of effects
including the fact that the nuclear
effects can give and emit light in
various ways we basically could tell
from what we saw that these were much
lighter like neutron stars are supposed
to be than the black hole events they
were a distance much closer than that
50 mega parsecs instead of 20 times that
that we saw for the black holes and
fortunately for us the signal was also
seen two seconds later in an
astronomical instrument that was the
Fermi satellite that monitors gamma-ray
bursts this is a picture of our signal
and put on there trace and where they
saw a signal over here is the same
pictures of the location on the sky our
location on the sky is these long
pictures here if it was just like oh but
when we add Virgo
it's this little ellipse here and this
is the position as determined by the
Fermi satellite one thing that makes me
feel great is that we're the ones that
actually have the better location even
though we're a beginners at this game so
and that's very important for the future
so this picture is what we think is the
indication of what the future is going
to pretend this particular event then
having the confidence that it was seeing
both in an electromagnetic instrument
the Fermi telescope and us could be
studied for hours days and weeks after
that and has been looking at
gravitational waves of course looking
for it with neutrinos looking with a
visible and infrared light radio waves
gamma rays and x-rays and so forth using
this a whole set of collaborations in
Kaku
agents have been made from this one
observation already which by the way we
announced only a little over a month ago
two weeks after the Nobel announcement
we announced the merger of two neutron
stars so even after whatever we got this
price for we're still producing very
interesting new things I'll just give
you a glimpse I'm out of time
and a few of the different kinds of
phenomenon that are cut and
interpretation that came out of this
single first coincidence event with
electromagnetic instruments kind of to
whet your tongue at what's going to
happen in the future the first is an
independent pretty independent
measurement of what's called the Hubble
constant this is basically the rate at
which the universe is expanding it's
done by in this case optically
identifying what galaxy it was in and
then otherwise from the information we
have in the gravitational wave signal
and the answer is so-called Hubble
constant is independent of and
consistent with the answers that came in
electromagnetic interactions the second
which I won't go through in any detail
is that there's been a lot of
phenomenology of what happens when
objects like these neutron stars come
together we all know what a supernova is
the collapse of a star when it gets old
and dies the this is tabbed a Killa Nova
the consequence of this coming together
and that's been studied now in all these
different instruments and put together
and compared with some of the
phenomenology that's been developed for
a killer nova and at least the general
idea confirmed one consequence which is
interesting is the possibility that we
have actually figured out our scene what
makes heavy elements in the sky in the
heavy elements of puzzle has always been
how on earth do we have very heavy
elements where did
they come from you can go on a mine and
if I'm gold or platinum or other heavy
elements where do they come from we know
most of the universe is made of the
hydrogen and helium we know how to make
everything up to iron very easily it's
made in the same fusion process that
makes the Sun the Sun burns but making
heavier elements in nature we don't
really know we do know how to make them
in the lab we make them all the time in
the periodic table has gone up quite
high we basically take a heavy element
and bombard it with neutrons it sounds
familiar neutron stars so the neutrons
are the way we do it in the laboratory
so the idea is very tempting that maybe
in nature its collisions like we just
observed that is neutron star collisions
that made heavy elements this graph here
is one phenomenological interpretation
of that and the yellow parts which
you'll notice are mostly yellow for gold
and platinum which you might have on
your hand are come from merger of
neutron stars at least in this analysis
and so maybe all the gold and platinum
that we sell on the earth we finally
discovered comes from collisions like
we've just announced a rather
interesting conclusion lastly I just
want to end with the future for a minute
or two we have now three detectors
working well soon have two more we have
one we're building in India a LIGO with
the collaboration of the Indian
physicists and Indian government that'll
be ready in the 2025 era there's one in
Japan that has some advanced techniques
which I'll mention which which should be
working within the next few years giving
us better localization this is an
incremental plot of how well we think
we'll be able to locate the position on
the sky as we move into the 2020s and
you can see that with the addition of
the other detectors independent of where
something comes from we should be able
to tell very well where it is and
combine then with electromagnetic
information we have ideas and also plans
for the future I want to end on that
first as I showed you we're still about
a factor of two away from the design of
advanced LIGO that we will do over the
next few years again in a matter of
steps and that gives us almost a factor
of 10 2 cubed in the rate or the
significance of individual events we
have concepts for getting beyond that we
we know that we should at least think
and do the Rd and possibly ask to be
funded for a concept that would exploit
our sites where we have ly go to their
axilla 610 and so we've basically done
conceptual designs of that we can
improve by making a much heavier test
mass by using a different material in
the mirrors we're presently looking at
silicon by lowering the temperature
modestly by improving a limitation we
have that is the coatings the optical
coatings on the mirrors that Ray showed
and by making yet a more powerful laser
if we do that we can get down to the
black curve that's shown in this plot
here and that will enable us to have
more cosmological reach which which will
be talked about by Kip some of the ideas
of what we might be able to do improve
signal the noise which what we've
learned is that we need to have events
where we have such good signal-to-noise
that we can determine things like the
orientation of the spins of the black
holes and so forth and an event rate
that's maybe 10 times advanced LIGO if
we in it put in all these this will
require Rd and we haven't yet the
funding and haven't firmly proposed to
do it the next steps are to goo to do
other reactions that we can do on the
Earth's surface but also and this is
some of those as possible
and Kip will talk about those but it's
already basically in this community
ideas that
fairly well-developed for how you would
move to the next generation detector
it's completely possible we don't see
any great technical hurdles in
extrapolating this up to a detector
that's a factor of 10 are so better than
present detectors what's the right
detector is what we have to work on and
to do that we have to set our priorities
in science we can't do everything
there's two main concepts right now on
the table one is to go underground make
the detector cryogenic so it's cooler
this very much helps the lower
frequencies we're going underground
there's a shaking of the earth cooling
the detectors you have less thermal
noise this is a concept that's been
developed in Europe and it's called the
Einstein telescope and they've been
working on it for about five to five or
so years and it's pretty firmly designed
maybe not costed but at least the
concept is fully designed in the US
we've been looking at another approach
which is to make basically a LIGO liked
detector but much bigger that is to make
a detector that's 40 kilometers instead
of 4 kilometers you'll remember from
Ray's talk that length basically you
gain linearly so if we can make it 40
detectors and do everything else as well
we're ten times better basically and
this would be then on the Earth's
surface which is cheaper but we have to
worry about the fact that there's
Earth's curvature in that length it's
has arms that are 40 kilometers and
basically would have to have the
instrumentation that we use in initial
like oh this R&D is just starting it's
being led by Matt Evans who's probably
somewhere up here I can't see him in
developing a group that actually will
develop this concept over the next few
years we hope to develop both the
science priority so that we know what
has to be done what we want to do and to
begin to do the serious R&D that would
go into such detectors overall and this
is just a precursor of race of Kip's
talk the science as we move to the
future is going to be very much like
what has happened in astronomy as
astronomy started by Galileo looking
through a telescope at visible light we
know now we do astronomy by looking at
visible light x-rays infrared so forth
and so on
the same thing is true here that we can
look at light we can look at
gravitational waves in a particular
frequency band on the Earth's surface
it's what's available to us where it's
quietest and that's the audio band if we
want to look at other frequencies we
have to use different methods the most
close to being done because it's
approved and funded is to do an
experiment in fit in space it's called
Lisa it'll move into the frequency band
of 10 to the minus 1 to 10 to the minus
4 Hertz instead of 10 to a thousand ten
thousand Hertz like ourselves and that
covers a different frequency band and
what's shown above and I'll leave that
to Kip to talk about is both some of the
same phenomenon looked at him at an
earlier time in their evolution and
other phenomenon that never reached the
frequencies that we get on the earth you
can look at yet lower frequencies one
concept that's being developed now that
I don't have time to talk about is to
use a timing from radio pulsars and
that's being looked at looking for
signals at very lower frequencies by
monitoring the time coming and we're
looking for changes from a set of radio
pulsars and lastly there are ways to get
the effect of gravitational waves from
the early universe which is the most
interesting of all in most of our minds
when and if it can be done and all the
other aid to talk about those thank you
[Music]
thank you very much and the third
presentation will be given by Professor
thorne who is a theoretician in the
field of general relativity and he has
made predictions about the waves created
by different Astrophysical events and
what signals they would be anticipated
from these and as we have heard he is
also one of the pioneers and cofounders
of mango so please
[Music]
thank you can you hear me I'm so pleased
to see so many of my like over goal
colleagues here I just want to thank you
for making me look so good I really
think of myself as more of an icon for
this collaboration and this Nobel Prize
is really something that I accept as a
representative of you who have made this
great success in the end I would like to
highlight the fact that the where we are
and where we are going in gravitational
wave astronomy and physics has relied on
three different efforts each of which
was roughly a half a century long in
order to get where we are and where
we're going
the first was discussed in considerable
detail by Ray Weiss and Barry barish the
experimental effort and a little bit
along with that the data analysis effort
I want to talk about the theoretical
effort on understanding sources of
gravitational waves the waveforms that
are produced the shapes of the waves
produced by the these sources and the
information that is carried by those
waveforms then I want to talk briefly
very briefly about a third effort it
says lasted for about a half a century I
combine theoretical and experimental
effort on what is called quantum non
demolition that's a buzzword but I'll
explain what that buzzword means then I
will move into the future focusing on
what we where we might be in the 2030s
the four different frequency bands that
Barry barish introduced you to and then
beyond the twenty thirty so this is
where I'm going in this talk let me just
look at ya okay just looking at the time
here okay so so I want to begin however
with some personal remarks I was a
graduate student at Princeton in the
period 1962 to 1965 my thesis adviser
was John Archibald wheeler a fabulous
man
who had what seemed at the time wild
ideas most of which have come to be out
too turned out to be true he was
focusing and he taught me about neutron
stars and black holes but I also was a
hanger-on on the fringes of Bob Dickies
experimental gravity research group of
which Ray Weiss at the time was a member
a doesn't remember me in graduate school
but I remember him because he was a real
intellectual giant in Bob Dickies group
and I was sort of sitting back there as
a mouthy theorist trying to understand
the experimental side of this subject
but I'm so glad I did because I learned
enough to in the end be able to
collaborate with ray Weiss Ron dreamer
very bearish right
I was also much influenced by Joseph
Weber whom ray talked about Joe I met
and spent a lot of time within the
French Alps at a summer school lasers in
a zoo near Xiamen e we went hiking in
the Alps and he told me all about his
plans and the experimental work that he
was already getting going on
gravitational wave detection and so it
was quite natural when I went to Caltech
in 1966 as a professor a young professor
that I would build a theory group that
worked in black holes neutron stars and
the theory of gravitational waves by
1972 together with colleagues and
students I'd begun to develop some
amount of vision for the science that
might be done with gravitational waves
the information that might be extracted
from gravitational waves and the key
idea is this in a general form that
there are only two kinds of waves that
can propagate across the universe
bringing us information about what's
very far away electromagnetic waves and
gravitational waves and that's it
according to the laws of physics and
there's an enormous difference between
the two types of waves electromagnetic
waves or oscillations of the
electromagnetic field that propagate
through space as time passes by contrast
gravitational waves are actually
oscillations of the fabric or shape of
space and
I'm extremely different kinds of
phenomena electromagnetic waves are
generally in astrophysics incoherent
superpositions of emission from
individual particles and atoms and
molecules whereas your gravitational
waves are produced by their coherent
bulk motion of large amounts of mass or
energy electromagnetic waves are all too
easily absorbed and scattered as they
travel through the universe so we only
see a small portion of the universe
because there's so much obscuration by
gas and dust
whereas gravitational waves are never
significantly absorbed or scattered even
if they're emitted near the Big Bang
with those differences it became very
quite clear and I think it was clear to
my theorist colleagues and students by
1972 many sources of gravitational waves
will never be seen electromagnetically
and the colliding black holes that we
have seen thus far there's been no
electromagnetic signal that surprises
then are likely and there's a potential
to revolutionize our understanding of
the universe using this radically
different kind of waves so that was what
we had in mind already by the early
1970s and that was the same time 1972
Israeli Weiss having gone from Princeton
back to MIT has a young professor he
wrote a classic paper in which he
described the design for a in her
interferometer gravitational wave
detector and he identified all the major
noise sources these kinds of detectors
might have to deal with and how you
would deal with each of them and what
kinds of sensitivity you could get as a
result and he concluded that there was a
real chance to be able to build
detectors that could reach the
sensitivities that were required by the
sources that my colleagues and I were
thinking about now I looked at Ray's
ideas
and I stated in a textbook a classic
textbook that I wrote was John wheeler
my thesis advisor and Charles misser but
these are not very promising he was
telling us that you should build a
detector that measures the motions of
masses with ten to the minus twelve one
trillionth of the amplitude of motion
compared to the wavelength of the light
you're using you measure a detector that
moves by an amount that is one one
thousandth the diameter of the nucleus
of an atom and an atom nucleus is a
hundred thousand times smaller than an
atom I mean it just was crazy
and then I studied his paper which he
didn't publish in the regular literature
he put in an internal report at MIT
because his attitude was you don't
publish something like this until you've
detected gravitational waves but I he
disseminated it's quite widely among his
colleagues I read it
and I began to think well maybe this
will work I had this long night long all
night discussion with him in Washington
do you see that he referred to
I had discussions with Vladimir Baginski
in Moscow and later with Ronald Reaver
whom we brought to Caltech to start the
Caltech effort I became convinced and it
seemed to me that because the potential
of this for human future understanding
the universe is so great that I should
do everything that I could as a theorist
to help my experimental colleagues
succeed and so here I am I and my
students in the end draw to probably 70%
of our effort research effort from then
on July go let me now talk about sources
of gravitational waves 1978 we had a
workshop on sources of gravitational
waves gathered together essentially all
of the theorists and experimentalists
not here because he hasn't joined into
this fee
yeah although he did play a crucial role
and get helping us get Caltech into the
field behind the scenes on a committee
that recommended that we move forward in
the field and at that workshop at the
end there was a discussion of strengths
of sources and this comes from the paper
describing the workshop supernova where
an upper limit was here that's ten to
the minus twenty-one this is frequency
this is the strain that we've been
talking about compact binary mergers
that's black hole binary to black holes
two neutron stars a black hole neutron
star estimated to be in this region and
so it seemed clear to us that the talk
goal had to be to reach a sensitivity of
a strain sensitivity of ten to the minus
twenty one and so we even had t-shirts
made up that said ten to the minus
twenty one or bust there is the signal
it came in the first thing that was seen
one times ten to the minus twenty one
that's obviously largely luck that we
were right on the money but that was our
goal beginning in nineteen seventy eight
and that's where the first thing that
came in 1983 when we were planning legal
it seemed pretty clear to me the likely
first detection was binary black holes
and this is basically what I argued from
then on though I think most of the
community was expecting it to be two
neutron stars but it seemed to me
already then that the following would
outweigh the neutron stars were first
for the black holes in favor of new
truck black holes instead of neutron
stars the distance to which you could
see a signal for two objects going
around each other the approximately
proportional of the masses of the
objects we were thinking of the time
that the black holes we would be dealing
with were maybe ten times heavier than
neutron stars so you would see a volume
of the universe there would be a
thousand times greater than four neutron
stars and that seemed to me that would
outweigh the lower absolute numbers of
black holes there are in the universe
compared to neutron stars and that's how
it did turn out to be but we were very
uncertain as to how strong these waves
were
but we knew it was somewhere in the
vicinity of that 10 to the minus 21
numerical simulations were going to be
needed it seemed very clear to me in
that era in order to be able to extract
the information from the colliding black
holes that they carry because we could
not with pencil and paper and analytical
techniques we could not solve Einstein's
equations to compute the shapes of the
gravitational waves coming from
colliding black holes so we had to do it
by numerical relativity so let me go
back a brief history of numerical
simulations this begins in the 1950s
motivated by Johnny wheeler my thesis
adviser who told us already in the 1950s
that we should try to study the
veritable storms in the fabric of space
and time that occur when space and time
the geometry of space and time are
highly excited in a nonlinear fashion
and rapidly changing and we had and he
said you go out and study this thing
that I called geometric dynamics we
tried we fell flat on our faces we
didn't have the tools to do it but he
recognized and the his students around
him recognized that in order to really
sort do this you had to do it
numerically so you'd be had to begin to
build the tools of solving Einstein's
equations and numerically on a computer
or computer simulations so the
foundations were laid in the ferret
period from 58 to 64 by Charles Messner
Richard link whist who were associated
with Johnny wheeler
Susan Hahn who was a computer scientist
at IBM who came DUP with Richard
Lindquist to start this out this is the
best photograph I can find a link West
in that era it was not however until
1978 the first successful collision a
simulation was done of head-on
collisions of two black holes by Larry
Smarr and Kenneth F Lee building on
foundations laid by Bryce to it and
earlier foundations of Misner Han and
Lindquist there are a number of other
contributors in this period I'm
highlighting the people who were really
the giant
in this early era so here 58 to 78 this
is 20 years already the struggling to
get this started
next was the problem of doing two black
holes that circle around each other then
spiral together collide and merge and
the community began to work on that and
it became a very concerted effort by
1983 when we were ready I started when
we were co-founding LIGO and we were
telling our colleagues doing these
simulations we really need these
simulations in order to extract
information from the waste that we will
see by the 1990s there was a something
called the binary black hole Grand
Challenge Alliance led by Richard
Matzner at the University of Texas all
of the world's experts in this getting
together and working in a concerted sort
of away and I became a little concerned
that was going more slowly than it
should be so I made a bet I like to make
bets and I made a bet that I hereby
wager that lie you will discover
convincing gravitational waves from
black hole coalescence or merger before
the numerical relativity community has a
cold capable of computing waveforms I
wanted to lose this bet in the worst
possible way I wanted to lose this bet
by the early 2000 site pain came alarmed
the progress really was slower than the
experimental progress why was it slow
it's been really hard you're trying to
simulate not two things that collide in
space and time you're simulating things
they're made out of warp space in time
that are colliding so you don't have an
arena in which this is going on you're
simulating the arena itself a warped
arena which says this is going on and so
by the early two-thousands I became
alarmed and so I started in
collaboration with Salter Kolski at
Cornell what we call the sxs
collaboration to work in this field Saul
had been working on this already for a
few years and 2004 the first successful
simulations are done by Franz Pretorius
a postdoc in our group
Jones central emanuelle accompany Lee
and their research groups by 2014 the
simulations were mature enough for the
first Lyle observations and I conceded
the bet with great happiness and when
the server signal came in in September
14 2015 the numerical relativity
gravitational wave form is the red here
the observed wave form is the gray and
that matched beautifully and by
comparing those waves the theoretical
and the observational with each other we
inferred the properties of the black
holes and the distance to the sources
this is a you can then go back knowing
from the observations of the comparison
of the theoretical waveforms of the
observational waveforms you can go back
and look at the simulations and see what
was happening during those simulations
and this is a simulation of the
colliding black holes as seen from
outside our universe looking in on the
warped shape of space and time around
the black hole the red is the slowing of
time the arrows are the dragging of
space into motion is a gigantic splash
in the shape of space and the slowing of
time and then an oscillation the
gravitational waves go propagating out
you can also compute what it would have
looked like to your eyes if you had seen
the two black holes go around each other
collide and merge creating what's called
gravitational lensing distorting the
star field that's behind the two black
holes and the this is a movie that was
played extensively at the time of the
first discovery that came again from
this XSS collaboration it was essential
that we not only had numerical
relativity simulations but for the
earlier parts of the waveforms they were
computed by a different technique called
post-newtonian expansion which I won't
go into detail but that was another
40-year effort led primarily by loop one
shanty-boat amor and then the matching
the two together by a different
technique
led by keyboard Oh Maura and Alessandra
born on Oh so that was the way we had
the wave farms that we needed quantum
not emulation I just want to mention
very briefly because I'm also running
out of time the challenge is to monitor
the motions of 40 kilogram mirrors to a
precision that is 10 to the minus 17
centimeters which turns out to be
approximately the half width of the
quantum mechanical wave function of the
center of mass degrees of freedom of
these mirrors so the challenge in
advanced LIGO is to deal with quantum
flexural quantum fluctuations of the
motions of the mirrors themselves to
circumvent the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and this means that for the
first time in advanced LIGO humans see
human sized objects behave quantum
mechanically and that has required
developing a field of technology called
quantum Don demolition technology to
deal with this this is a branch of
modern quantum information science
it was Vladimir Bergen see in 1968 that
told us we need to do to do this no
matter what kind of gravity wave
detectors rebuilt I didn't understand
what he was saying for 10 years and then
I finally understood and then I had my
research group work as closely as
possible with his research group to work
out the techniques for this I'm running
out of time I'm going to skip over my
discussion of the techniques for this
except to say that the key idea which
comes primarily from Carlton caves and
from Bill unruhe
is that you take the vacuum of quantum
electrodynamics the vacuum fluctuations
of light and you modify that vacuum by
what is called squeezing and you inject
the squeezed vacuum into the back end of
the interferometer it's it sounds just
crazy but this turns out to be
absolutely crucial for the future of
this field when we go beyond advanced
LIGO I want to wind up like briefly
talking about
gravitational-wave astronomy in the
2030s there are four different frequency
bands that Barry bearish talked about
the low frequency band minutes to hours
to be studied by Lisa these four three
spacecraft attract each other with laser
beams it's a ISA mission we hope that it
launches by about 2030 and lisa is
capable of monitoring the gravitational
waves from giant black holes millions of
Suns that spiral around each other
collide and merge with Sigma noise
ratios of 10,000 or more and thereby
capable of studying geometry dynamics
with unbelievably high precision pulsar
timing arrays a gravitational wave
sweeps across the earth and it speeds up
or slows down all the clocks on the
earth and so naturally if you time the
radio time pulsars at different
locations on this guy they will all slow
down and speed up our pair to slow down
to speed up in synchrony because it's
the clocks on the earth that are being
screwed up and that technique will look
at great super giant black holes
billions of Suns in mass so we cover the
whole range some solar mass scale of
black holes and millions of solar masses
to billions of solar masses and a small
black hole going orbiting around a large
black hole generates gravitational waves
that carry a full map of the large black
hole that is being explored by the small
black hole as the small black hole goes
around it in orbits and here's the small
black hole going around the large black
hole the orbit is wildly crazy because
of the dragging of space into motion by
the big black hole as well as other
relativistic effects and it's samples
essentially the entire space around the
big black hole and it gives us then the
information to do exquisitely accurate
mapping of the geometry space and time
around big black holes what are the
central bodies not a black hole for
example the naked singularity the orbits
will be wryly different and the maps
will be wildly different so we have the
capabilities search for out
expect the kinds of massive central
bodies I want to wind up by saying that
we have a potential to study the
earliest moments of the universe by the
2030s when the universe was at an age of
10 to the minus 12 seconds there is
predicted to have been a electroweak
phase transmission where the
electromagnetic force and the weak force
come apart and gain their own individual
identities the birth of the laws of
electromagnetism and this may have
occurred in what's called a first order
phase transition inside bubbles the
bubbles of the new phase where
electromagnetic force does exist in the
bulk of the old face where it doesn't
exist collide produce gravitational
waves which today have been redshift
into Lisa's frequency band and like.oh
could see similar phase transitions that
would have occurred when the universe
was ten to the minus twenty two seconds
so we have no idea what was going on in
the universe at age twenty ten to minus
twenty two seconds primordial
gravitational waves coming off of the
Big Bang itself are predicted to have
been amplified whatever came off the Big
Bang amplified by inflation in the first
ten to the minus thirty three seconds of
the universe theoretical prediction that
is pretty even strongly believed by the
theoretical physicists and what is
speculated to come off the Big Bang is
vacuum fluctuations the minimum amount
of fluctuations the gravitational field
that are possible they would get
amplified to make a rather rich spectrum
of real gravitational waves that would
propagate out interact with a hot plasma
in the universe is 383 380,000 years old
and put out polarization on the Cosmic
Microwave Background produced by the hot
electrons at that age which would be
seen today and so they challenged the
people who work with the Cosmic
Microwave Background is to measure
definitively that polarization thereby
infer the gravitational waves that came
off the Big Bang can volved with the
effects of inflation so the spectrum the
would be seen is a convolution a
combination of the effects of inflation
and what came off the Big Bang we also
have the potential by 2050 to fly a
successor to the Lisa mission which be
capable of seeing these gravitational
waves from the earliest moments of the
universe independently at periods of a
few seconds so imagine you have the
gravitational wave with periods of a few
seconds you have their prime motive
gravitational waves with periods of
hundred million years seen by
polarization on this guy polarization
pattern on the sky both of them are
produced by whatever came off the Big
Bang convolved with the effects of
inflation and I envisioned that by the
2050s those will not agree there will
not be an agreement between what's
coming off at periods of one of a few
seconds at periods of 100 million years
and there will be a huge mystery what
really came off the Big Bang why was it
not vacuum fluctuation so that's my
dream of the future and that at that
point those observations may really feed
into understanding the laws of quantum
gravity that govern the birth of the
universe so let me just conclude by
saying it was 400 years ago that Galileo
created modern electromagnetic astronomy
by turning a small optical telescope on
the sky and discovering the moons of
Jupiter it was two years ago
that this wonderful lionel virgo
collaboration turned on the advanced
detectors the advanced LIGO detectors
and saw the gravitational waves from
collisions of two black holes in those
four hundred years since Galileo we have
learned so much about the universe with
optical Astronomy our understanding of
the universe is so different today than
it was 400 years ago thanks to off
tickle astronomy what might be the
future 400 years from now when we have
400 years in our pockets of
gravitational astronomy together with
electromagnetic astronomy I think the
future is really very very
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so I I would not cost professor Mike and
mr. Barry
[Applause]
so if you go over to the bar in the
front of the stage so you you can
advance the liquid
[Music]
[Applause]
okay